welcome to this video against muchacha
me which I cami okay no name
yeah it's um a Japanese like yeah now
even the well-known zai like to recheck
sometimes there are those like that just
look like one but something different
okay if we could have one idea three g3
set up this year with rupee 184 is a
pretty solid line that I play from time
to time
you know it normally it is it is
obviously nothing that will kill black
out right but it is quite nice to play
white will play Queen b3 95 or 92 c4 you
have some some little pressure based on
the bishop on g2 simply because black
has a hard time to not ever play c5 or
efile this kind of moves if I was very
difficult to play well well well you
have to force it through maybe now if he
goes e5 but I have Bishop g5 and it's
also not not that great yeah
so very often you get a position like
that where why it has like the two
bishops and he can basically shuffle
around forever and try for a little
advantage let's see yeah okay he's
really opening it up Oh interesting
I didn't expect that move okay d5
probably yeah that's a bit more
interesting than taking taking is very
stale
to see to want to see if I go to see
form b5 I don't have any great square so
I better go back
this also has some additional ideas if
it takes on d5 which I don't know
probably you will do Bishop d5 I have
ideas like Bishop takes h6 then Queen g6
okay that's not going to happen okay so
let's take and now yeah I'm guess I'm
going to to win this to gain the space
if he allows me to do that I will I will
take the space
k2 is six
yeah the night might come to g5 but I
can I can take it if it arrives to them
you see going to place see five maybe
now let's get out of the seafoam I want
to recapture with the a pond so that 94
is not possible okay let's get into this
pin
Bishop T hive maybe should be five film
protecting my queen and maybe
threatening at some point to take ecigs
take g6 for Bishop c5 winning a pod
that's an idea
yeah I'm threatening Bishop e6 rookie
six Luke g6 route 66 Bishop 65 and I'm a
pawn up it's a slightly annoying threat
now okay so is getting he he got out of
that but now I have b5 right b5 and I
think I have managed to secure the pawn
with C form or a form a force of course
the better the better way to do it
c4 gives up the d4 square yes that's a
very nice position now pen let's see how
to continue I want to do that I would
like to double on the D fall I can I can
do this right now what I want to I want
to prevent c4 even as a pawn sacrifice
so that he cannot escape somehow
activate his pieces the night on e6 is a
very very passive piece and I just want
to double on the D file and then
possibly take he can never move the
knight to somewhere important as f7 is
hanging
yeah it's an excellent end game here or
well almost end game okay I can take now
only six on Bishop c6 is also quite
strong yeah when is this is a simple
tool to meet the CAPTCHA but it's it is
strong but can I do it leads to a very
very clear advantage it looks a bit
silly to to trade them to trade them the
bishop against the night but if it wins
it wins and this is very close to being
a win let's see
27:25 I'm sorry okay rook b7 where are
you going nowhere I guess I mean can go
to this six or to the eight but oh wait
let's think think for a moment I can
also take seven for Bishop c5 then he
has screen three seven as a possible
defense okay
now come on this this is a very easy
wind let let's do that don't do anything
fancy picking up the airport this
quickest actually the chicken then shall
March the apron I guess check check
time morning check
check
check
not quite not quite optimally played
what at it here but okay the pawns the
pawns will ultimately win this thing
it's just just a bit too much yeah but I
I lost a couple of moves that it wasn't
really necessary at all black for
effects on time yeah it wasn't very a
very nice position all of a sudden I'm
not I'm not totally convinced about what
happened from here I mean this this
looks nice but I don't really know I
mean c5 is a move I'm going for Quincy
form quickly so maybe he has to play
this at some point but this is a very
nice position now b5 immediately also
was was possible it it got even worse
after year played 85 you know after
after I got this end this is this is a
fantastic position really like this is
completely completely tied down I am
probably could have won this somewhat
somewhat quicker
yeah maybe here being a little bit more
patient like see for some more
improvement moves but okay it does win
it just that yeah I made it a little bit
difficult for myself here check check
but ultimately the points will win even
if this was a little bit a little bit
strange
yeah the problem here in general is if
we do back here here in this kind of
position we we have a structure where
black really has to be has to just stay
put he shouldn't really move any of his
pawns I mean II five sometimes as
possible if I'm forced to trade yeah if
I have to trade on e5 it's completely
symmetrical and very dull but in the
case where I'm I get this in I will have
a situation where he gives me a passed
pawn with c5 this is
for white he would he can take which
okay here I can even take with the Queen
er double-double attacking him but this
is not a convenient thing or he can can
play as he did 95 which leads to a
structure where I will probably take and
recapture and this is a weak pawn on c6
this Bishop is strong I have got two
bishops in a position that is opening up
its very that's a very inconvenient
situation what he actually has to do is
he has to just stay put like Knight f6
yeah and then just stay I can just
shuffle yeah it's not not much fun this
position for black because you have very
little in terms of activity that you can
do sometimes you can try like 85a for
this kind of things but it's it's very
slow yeah and what white can do I can
also try to slowly improve yeah I can
can play a King King g2 and maybe very
long-term I can try you have to crawl up
on the Kings side now preparing this of
course yeah with more more moves Queen
over and let's say to e2 or something
there are there are very slow plans
available for white it's nothing great
but it's a little bit more difficult for
black to play because black really can
absolutely do nothing it just has to
stay put okay well thanks for watching